[Music]
welcome to tbs yes what a great place
yeah we do like these people they're
very nice they're going to like it here
i'm curious about something uh is your
show a cougar town it's very funny show
what can you do differently now that
you're on tbs is it a different is it
going to change the dna of the show at
all well i think i mean i feel like we
can be a little racier i was actually
wearing my shirts lower because i felt
like now i'm on cable i should just show
more boobs
[Applause]
the reason why i decided to wear more
cleavage on the show is not necessarily
because of tbs is because i'm newly
married on the show and i thought you
know she needs to keep her marriage
alive and try right but then i started
thinking this might work out for me
because as i get older you know less
focus
more focus
just smart business is what i'm thinking
so you want to encourage people because
you're so beautiful but you're still
away from here you look fantastic but
then and then yeah well now i'm doing it
um
you know what when you wear low-cut tops
enough literally the crew is like oh god
to see those again i mean
no they aren't
no men don't get i don't care there's no
level of jade or field
nobody does that